the research on on couples is such that
most couples therapists can watch like a
five minute snippet of a couple argue oh
divorce with accuracies of over 90
percent oh
that's rough
I as a therapist I tend to think it's
great but okay yes
but it's not for the couple who's
arguing in that way why but why that is
is because it is how couples argue that
gives you a window into the relationship
satisfaction and longevity
it's how they process conflict and there
are several factors that have been shown
to you know both well for couples versus
both poorly for couples
[Music]
welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode 111 with guy winch guy
winch is a psychologist and author and
host of his own psychology podcast he
specializes in the topics of trauma
heartbreak and couples relationships
he's written several self-help books and
co-hosts a podcast called dear
therapists
which is pretty entertaining
I wanted to speak with him about the
subject of heartbreak how to heal a
broken heart he authored how to fix a
broken heart
for anyone having a hard time in your
relationship or trying to get over
someone this might help again like I
said last episode this is an episode
from about a month ago when things were
a bit crazy in my life I'll be doing a q
a soon to update everyone and things are
much better now I hope you enjoy this
episode and have a fantastic week if you
enjoy this content please remember to
hit subscribe
[Music]
Dr Guy winch welcome to my podcast thank
you so much for having me
I'm very excited to talk to you I had
somebody on Instagram reach out and say
you have to get this guy on he knows
everything about relationships and
heartbreak and Trauma and I've been on a
how to deal with trauma kick but I
thought for this episode we should talk
specifically about relationships and
heartbreak but before we get started
could you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
so I'm a psychologist and I also write
books I have three self-help books
um I also have three TED talks and I
have a podcast called the therapists
with co-host Laurie Gottlieb in which we
um have guests write us letters in which
they need advice but we bring them on
for actual kind of therapy session live
cool and then we give them advice and
then they have to do it and report back
on how it went so you kind of get a full
Arc of the story each week
oh that's interesting so you talk to
people and they come back on the podcast
to tell you how it's going and to tell
the audience yeah but not just that when
we do it we don't talk about the case
beforehand so my co-host and I we have
to jump in as two therapists blind not
knowing what the other one thinks and
try and navigate it to an interesting
place and so it's it's uh interesting
all along
that is interesting okay
so you have a number of self-help books
your most recent one what was your most
recent one about called how to fix a
broken heart it uh had a has a TED Talk
of the same name and it's about really
what happens to us when we have romantic
heartbreak
um because a lot happens to us okay so
let's start there then
um I remember
when I was I suppose this happens to
everybody somewhat but when I was little
like in grade nine or ten and had my
first real relationship and I thought I
was gonna grow up and get married to him
um and was 100 certain that was going to
happen and when we broke up I was just
distraught like unbelievably distraught
so what does happen
um with heartbreak
so two things actually first of all
what's interesting about heartbreak is
that thing that happened to you in 9th
or tenth grade happens to us in our 20s
in our 30s in our 40s we get similarly
distraught
um at all ages and I work with the
heartbroken people of all ages it kind
of doesn't matter how old you are if
you're truly heartbroken you are
heartbroken and what's interesting about
heartbreak is that there is no other
common experience in life because right
heartbreak is not something you'll see
in the diagnostic and statistical Manual
of mental disorders there's no such
thing
so it's just a life experience there is
no life experience like it and which can
take somebody who has no psychological
problems and render them non-functional
and almost a little bit crazy
um
in a blink that's what's so fascinating
about it there's no other thing
that the grief can make us you know very
very upset but we don't act out of sorts
we don't lose our mind and do things we
would never do otherwise we do with
heartbreak
okay so grief and heartbreak are are
separate they're separate I mean I
heartbreak is a form of grief it's one
that we don't recognize so much as a
sanctioned form of grief like we do
losing a first degree relative but our
reactions are as powerful and if we
recall back to that time you said you
were distraught people do get devastated
they feel like they've lost their worlds
they they can even as adults they can
sit in bed and not be able to eat or
sleep or function for days on end that's
all they can think about they they will
do desperate acts they would never
otherwise do and you're like what is
wrong with me that I'm doing this but
I'm just so desperate and so yeah it
really does a number on us
okay so can we talk a bit about exactly
what happened like why is it that
sometimes you're in a relationship and
then this happens to you and you're
distraught and kind of insane like you
said
um why is it that
why is it that that happens sometimes
and what exactly is happening is it
cortisol or
just on that level so what functional
MRI studies what brain scans have showed
is that um the same thing roughly the
same thing happens to our brain when uh
love is removed when the person we love
is removed from our life or they remove
themselves usually from our lives
um as happens when heroin addicts are
um uh withdrawing from heroin
and if you think about it that way it
kind of explains it because if you think
of a heroin addict who was withdrawing
yeah they would they would steal they
would do all kinds of terrible things
they would never otherwise do but
everyone goes well they were an addict
so that's how desperate they were as if
that explains if she does it explains
the level of desperation the level of of
change and behavior it's the same
mechanisms that are getting activated
when we're heartbroken and it's that
same level of absolute desperation
that you would see happening uh for an
addict so so that's the why I mean when
you look at the brain the brain's acting
very similar and it's
at least explains why people are so out
of swords
so is that is that for specifically like
an opiate withdrawal or is that just
withdrawal
injection the analogy was to opiate with
Joel's uh opiate uh withdrawal even to
cocaine withdrawal but to like real
substance withdrawal that you really you
know are looking for and I think the
opiate just kind of people associate
that behavior with yeah drug addictions
they're like oh yeah I know what that
looks like well it looks yeah same it
looks the same really as the the
shocking but unreasonable part
okay that's interesting that is kind of
what it feels like right when you're
going through it because you're like I
just want to see something that reminds
me of them again or something like that
just to get some sort of hit
okay so if you're trying that's why
you'll send 150 text messages just
waiting just to get one word response
for that hip exactly what you said yes
wow okay so what's the best whale way to
deal with heartbreak so say you're in a
relationship uh say you've been broken
up with
is it best to go cold turkey then and to
treat it kind of similar to an addiction
or to wean off how are you supposed to
deal with this well I if it's possible
because sometimes it's not but if it's
possible to do cold turkey I always
recommend cold turkey your goal when
you're heartbroken
um is to stop hurting should be right I
mean to get over the person yeah to get
over them you have to stop hurting to
stop hurting you have to reduce their
presence in your thoughts because right
at the beginning that's 95 of your
thoughts is them them them
um the more you reduce that the more
you're moving away from it the more
you're recovering from it the more the
less painful it becomes so that's the
goal so in order to diminish their
presence in your thoughts at the stage
time that you give them cold turkey is
the right way to go if it's possible
it's very very difficult to do as any
addict will tell you it's actually it's
actually very difficult to do and what
makes it even more difficult is that
almost in every case
there was a blind side involved and I
say that even in cases in which you know
people say to me like well it broke up
10 times over the past two years but I
never expected this one would be the and
I'm like wow you broke up 10 times and
this one
but the thing is that when when people
are looking to break up with us they I
mean unless they dated you know unless
it's you had two or three dates if it's
been anything of any kind of substance
most people will time it will like
decide okay I want to break up unless
it's a big fight in the moment which is
a minority of cases it's thought through
about when I'll do it and often often
they do it in a considerable way often
they do it because oh you know her big
thing is coming up next week so let's
not do it right before that I'll wait
till after all we have this vacation
plan things aren't terrible let's go on
that vacation let's just get through the
holidays and so everything seems fine
until they pull the trigger and then
suddenly like wait what happened things
will find a day ago
that's true
that's true I suppose it's difficult
with social media now too to not like
you know before if you were in a
different city or you just don't see
them around right and then you're not
thinking about them but now with social
media and Instagram it's a problem
you need to you need to do the great
thing and you need to block and unfollow
and befriend even if it's temporarily
you don't want to see what's going on
with them because to remind you they've
been thinking about this for a while so
they're way ahead of you in terms of
recovery and no one puts out there like
it's me crying into a pillow Instagram
picture you know they'll find the one
moment where they're happy and post that
meanwhile you're sitting there crying
into a pillow thinking like they're
completely over me well hey they've had
a major Head Start weeks months
sometimes years of a head start of
getting over you and B you know again
they're putting out this highly curated
image of look I'm fine everyone
so it's just gonna hurt to see it so
don't don't see it
okay now that makes sense um so does
that mean
say you've been going out with somebody
and you're really good friends with them
and you're no longer romantically
interested
does that mean friendships off the table
for X's
if temporarily I would say I mean I
always say for now take a few months or
however not to truly get over them now
if once you're truly over them and you
know that because it's not tugging at
you in that way you want to be friends
it doesn't hurt to be friends go at it
but the majority of people once it gets
there are like that's going to be
complicated we don't I don't need that
friendship the friend excuse and I say
excuse is because it is an excuse at the
beginning it's just no I can be friends
without actually having my guts ripped
out every time I talk to them and no you
can't not at the beginning
okay fair enough
when if you're in a relationship with
someone and you're trying to make it
work how do you know are there signs
that can tell you when you should leave
and when you should keep trying to make
it work
um that's such a great question because
it depends on all kinds of variables I
mean my general philosophy is if you can
keep working at it and you know I mean
relationships even ones that have lost
it to 40 50 years are a constant study
and working on things I mean
circumstance changes people you know
change so you honestly you constantly
have to shift and tweak and work on
things so so My Philosophy is if you can
keep working
and oh by the way which means together
not you unilaterally in your head doing
what you think the relationship needs
without the other person participating
in that or being aware you're doing it
if you can work and communicate together
for as long as you can you should unless
you're both like we can but we're both
unhappy but otherwise yeah I mean
because I just think that's the if you
have something invested there why why
not
if things are mutual
okay how do you get over somebody if you
can't stop thinking they were you know
the one person for you or if you tried
dating you know say you went out for
with 15 people just like small dates
some sort of Tinder style dating and you
found this one person you had a great
relationship for a few years and you
thought they were the one and then that
falls apart how do you get over the
mindset of
that was the one person that was for me
that's a very hard thing to do but one
thing I always suggest to people is kind
of what you said in other words there's
not the one or my soulmate makes it
sound like you know seven and a half
billion people on the planet I lost
count I think seven and a half whatever
billion people there's one a one that
matches me and it's like no no they're
probably many hundreds of thousands that
match you it took you 15 of those tender
style you know explorations to find this
one maybe that's your ratio you got a
you know 1 in 15 is the one for you all
that means is yeah you've got to get out
there and start getting those numbers in
and and finding the next one once you're
free to do that so people get lost in
the thing you know get trapped into the
thing it's the only person it's not the
only person it might be hard for you to
find someone
which might be true for you but then all
right then the sooner you start looking
when you feel up to it then it might
take a while but you will if you keep
looking it's hard for you you just have
to generate more options eventually you
will right so so rather than take the
one person as the sign there's only one
take them as no it's possible to find if
I put that much work into it so now I
know how much work I have to put into it
to find it again once I'm over this
person obviously
yeah so how do you know when to get into
the dating Market again
you know it's it's tough people always
kind of ask me like how do I know if
it's too soon yeah I want another date
and I basically well if you can make it
through without crying is my
scientifically rigorous standard you can
make it through without you know
bursting entities
um you might be ready because you know
it part of getting becoming ready is
flexing those muscles again is putting
yourself out there is you know you know
interacting in that way is flirting and
you know texting and trying to get
banter going I mean that's part of
getting yourself ready is kind of
revisiting those those social muscles
that we don't use when we're in a
relationship as much in that in that in
um you know to meet someone at least in
that way so it's this thing if you wait
until you're official already you've
waited too long and so you know as long
as you think you know what I think I
might be interested in someone you don't
have to be ready emotionally fully you
can say to a person I'm recently out of
a relationship I want to take this slow
but if there's someone who at least on
paper even theoretically seems that
might be interesting to you then take it
slowly and see you know again if you're
too preoccupied you're not paying
attention to what person saying and you
certainly don't talk about it yes you
know on those dates the definite rule
don't don't discuss it because that'll
be a you know it's not good but um it's
not attractive and it'll trigger you um
but if you can get if you can do that
then try it out trial an error
okay I would say that's that's Sound
Advice
I haven't been in like a dating around
for a very long time so I don't know
what the dating Market looks like now
but how do you feel about how people are
meeting each other nowadays I mean given
the given kovid too things have gotten a
little weird in the last couple years
but even before that with like I
mentioned Tinder whatever other app
people are using
where you kind of just see this snapshot
and you're doing like swiping right and
left is that
is that okay is that healthy are there
problems with that or your views on that
I think my views are mixed I think most
people even the users views mixed in
some way there's the I mean the number
one pro of the apps is convenience
you know when I was you know a teenager
and adult it was before social media you
actually had to go somewhere
yeah you know you actually have to be in
a bar or be at this or or be somewhere
um where you
will meet someone and then you actually
get to see them in person and this whole
issue of chemistry is a little clearer
because you've actually met them in
person rather than seen just pictures or
videos or whatever so there was an
advantage to that
um the convenience is you can do this
from your own home the inconvenience is
that it there's so many people on there
who are not really looking to meet who
are really just there because they just
want to you know get the attention or
they just want to pass the time or they
just want to stick it to the person
they're with by going on there like
people have very different oh they're
about to go on a trip for a month so
just before they go but really they're
not available
so you're waving through a lot of people
who seem to be available but actually
are not and that you don't know until
you're doing all the swiping and then
people aren't responding and you're like
it must be me and it like a lot of the
times it's nothing to do with you
they're actually not available or
they're actually not there for that
they're not really serious about meeting
you know they just want to kind of see
what's out there almost like they're you
know reading the newspaper they're not
really serious about it so you don't
know and you have to yeah all of the all
of those people to maybe find the people
who are serious
this episode is brought to you by true
local true local partners with local
farmers and butchers in your area to
Source the best meat and deliver it to
your door things like 100 grass-fed and
grass-finished beef pasture-raised or
rwa chicken raised without antibiotics
lamb bison liver and more I recommend
their grain-fed beef I think it tastes
better wild salmon and their lamb is
Bomb they also have over 100 different
cuts of meat that you can't find at your
grocery store most likely to get started
just go to True local trulocal dot ca
for Canadians or
trulocalusa.com for Americans to build
your own personalized box of meat shows
up at your door vacuum sealed and
individually portioned which is perfect
for meal prep
also by an air fryer just throw those
steaks in Frozen that's the biggest life
hack I have use code MP to get free
stake in your order at trulocal.ca or
trulocalusa.com code MP for free steaks
I hope you enjoy the rest of this
episode
about ways to date that's more effective
than Tinder dating or something like
that given the fact that a lot of people
on those apps are hell some of them are
even in relationships and they're just
like Curious so they're not actually
looking for something long-term are
there long-term dating strategies that
you'd recommend
yeah look the one thing I always
recommend is that what is the thing that
you are passionate about what is the
thing that you you know really feels
like a part of you it's something that
you engage in it's part of your identity
you might be a runner you might be you
know into this band you might be a
sports fan you might be in a sports team
you might whatever it is you might enjoy
this kind of concert or this kind of art
if you find a way to engage in that with
other people
then the people you are likely to meet
there at least have one thing in common
with you you're both passionate or
you're both interested in doing
something and I use running just because
for runners it's actually a big you know
if you're a runner then you spend many
hours a week running obviously and so
that's a lot of hours that if you met
somebody in a running group that you
have in common and so and that's a great
way to know someone so if you can like
two birds with one stone if you can like
Dual Purpose it and do the thing that
interests you in the first place and
perhaps there meet the person who's
interested in the same thing that I
think is a great way to to meet somebody
in person
then you have things in common as well
right off the bat one and it's a passion
yeah
okay how do you feel about couples who
date each other who have nothing in
common
yeah
um you mean the ones that show up in my
therapy office
um yeah probably yeah because that's
what often happens
um
couples are sometimes together in a lot
of circumstance right they met in
college or they were working together
and and that circumstance made them feel
like there was a lot in common but
remove the circumstance and there's not
it turns out and and you get couples of
really or couples who've met young and
just Grown Apart and you feel like well
their lives are about all of these
things and the other person's lives
about a whole lot of other things and
there's so little over that there's so
little that they're truly interested in
with one another those are the couples
that are most likely to drift
emotionally from one another and to
start to feel lonely even though they
are together because loneliness happens
a lot within relationships and it can be
profound that it happens within
relationships but but that's what you
would expect because that area of
overlap that communication kind of you
know kind of just like Fizzles out
because it's just not that much binding
them
hmm I've spoken to some other people on
the podcast I can't remember who and
I've asked a similar question which is
what happens if the person you're with
is very different from you and there
isn't a lot in common and some people
said it makes it more interesting but I
think
your way your thoughts might be more
accurate but is yeah what do you do okay
so what if you're in a relationship with
someone you guys don't have a lot of
overlap is there a way to fix that
yes now look what a lot of time happens
is that when people have kids that
becomes the common that becomes the
common one oh so have children
no no no no no no no no because just
getting you know when the kids are older
and when the kids leave they're back to
like uh yeah and why am I with you so it
doesn't you know that no I mean that
often happens Emptiness is often or even
not you don't have to wait emptiness
kids are teenagers they're not
interested in you as much they want to
be their friends with each other like oh
well we have that conversation tonight
uh you know that so and it's but you can
be very different but you can still have
overlap you can still have very
meaningful conversation you can be a
couple who talk together about all kinds
of things even if you are not you know
they're interested in X you're
interested in why but you're open to
hearing about this and they're open to
hearing about yours and they support you
in theirs and you support them in yours
and they can be overlapped there they
can be overlapped socially you might
really have one kind of purpose or one
kind of value or one kind of belief that
really binds you but there's got to be
some connective tissue and so you might
be very different but then the task
early on is we'll find the connective
tissue it could be sex it could be
physical attraction truly I mean that's
kept a lot of couples together because
you know yeah but while we just really
we are still really into each other
whatever it is that's that's the task
that find what their connective tissue
is for you
okay how do you feel about
couples working together what if that's
the connective tissue do they work
together yeah
um
for some couples that works very very
well and for some couples that
um that masks a relationship in other
words that makes it seem like they're
connected when in essence they're not
um and so yeah they work together well
but all their conversations are about
work they don't really talk about
themselves or the relationship just
about the relationship as work Partners
just about what do we do with this
account and this this and this this but
yeah how do we feel about one another
what do I need from you that I'm not
getting what do you need from me that
you're not getting those conversations
don't take place it becomes very
transactional that's also going to be a
recipe for eventual disengagement
because
you know work is great but then they're
going to have a vacation and realize now
what and then those are the all the kids
all they talk about is the kids because
it's the one connection they have and
they avoid any other conversation again
it's not a recipe that's gonna last or
bring happiness
long term you really have to and I kind
of believe that two people can find that
common ground but they have to mutually
look for it they have to be open to
exploring with one another opening
themselves up you know like really
trying to get to know one another like
you've been together for a while but get
to know one another again do you know
what she's thinking do you know what
he's feeding you know like if you put in
that work you can usually find the
common ground but it's got to be mutual
and and you know and intentional
okay
what would Common Ground look like if
you don't have common ground with
somebody like how do you dive into them
and try and figure out where the
commonalities are how do you even start
that
it's kind of exactly as you said it in
fact you just dive in and start to see
where the commonalities are again
couples have been together for a while
don't ask each other things because they
think they know each other so well they
don't have to ask they don't know what
are you thinking about what I'm seeing
on the news right now oh I just read
this what do you think about that and
that's not in a domain it could be
something they've read that's nothing to
do with one of them that they don't know
like oh I just saw that this happened in
the world what do you think about that
and it could be an area of the world
that never even spoke about before like
but explore that like hey I've never
done I don't know I use this Pottery
I've never done Pottery
um
you want to give that a try like search
for things that you would do or I know
we really travel well together let's
organize some weekend trips and explore
places I'll organize one you organize
the other if you go about literally that
search like go on the on the on the
hints you have of what works well
between you but just be open-minded and
truly kind of explore uh what you think
about certain things and what interests
you
um you know couples do this thing where
they binge watch TV shows and it's and
they feel like oh we're so connected we
binge watch a decision like if you
didn't talk between the episodes you're
not because it could have been anyone
sitting next to you like if you pose
between episodes and hey what'd you
think about that or wow what was good
what did you like what do you think will
happen even if there's a few minutes of
conversation about it you're making it a
mutual experience otherwise it's like
parallel play with kids he's playing
with one he's playing with another but
they're not really interacting it's less
connective so you wanna you can make it
more connective again there's an
intentionality that happens with that
that should happen with it
okay and it is this kind of getting to
know the other person is that something
you have to do for your entire
relationship if it's a 50-year long
relationship you just have to keep
finding this common ground or does that
just happen sometimes
okay you made that sound very exhausting
which it can be and I don't think it
needs to be continual you know but I
think that because you you know like you
don't you don't have to work on things
all the time but you there are periods
where you'll feel things are working
well and there are periods where you'll
feel you're drifting or things feel a
little bit different and that's when you
have to work on things so as long as one
of you as long as you check in with each
other every once in a while hey how are
we doing I noticed we've not been
talking as much so we seem to be a
little bit on edge maybe we should talk
about how we're doing and maybe we need
to you know like make some effort to do
whatever it is that we need from one
another like doing those check-ins you
know we go to physical checkups usually
it past a certain age or you go once a
year to get your blood work done
at least once or twice a year get your
emotional temperature taken you know
with your partner to me I would think
over a long course of a relationship and
then if there's a little bit of
something then address it
that makes sense
um how do you know when you're near the
beginning of a relationship how do you
know if you're falling in love with the
person or what you think that person is
especially if the relationship is new
what an amazing question and here's the
depressing answer here don't
um because at the beginning of a
relationship you have a few dots of
information would you connect to make a
you know a a a a a
Mona Lisa but that Mona Lisa is made
from like 10 or 15 day you know dots on
the canvas not from
the you know Exquisite brush Strokes
you're filling in a lot of blanks with
assumptions yeah a ton so you don't no
um it's always a process of getting to
know and reminding yourself as
unromantic as it sounds like don't know
everything yet here a couple of
Milestones I always point out number one
if you don't know how the person fights
when they're really angry
then you don't oh know them yet because
I know a lot of people who are great but
when they lose it they go from zero to
raving really quickly and if you haven't
seen that side of them and you might not
for months because things are wonderful
and honeymoon period and all of that but
then suddenly you see if if they're not
able to you know they can get angry but
if they're not able to communicate or to
resolve conflict or if they just act out
or if they really lose it that might be
a big issue in a relationship which you
might not find out about
for a while
um and the other thing is you don't know
how they are under stress some people
for example I say have you traveled
together because some people travel
great and some people the minute you
give them a plane ticket in their hand
become a bowl of annoying stress they're
irritable and they're sharp and they're
sweating and they're panicked and
they're anxious and it's like this is
not a fun way to start
holiday but you don't know that you know
until all that they've been a really
stressful time at work how do they
manage stress can they lean on you are
you able to help them do they shut you
out do they so there's certain things
that you don't find out early on but
they're actually crucial for the
potential longevity uh or you know
liability of a relationship so so you
you have to remember that you're still
you know when we're dating we're putting
forth our best selves right this is the
this is the brochure version you get
this is the pamphlet this is that
everything's you know like people should
be on that best behavior it doesn't tell
you what the normative behavior is it
just tells you what their efforts are
that's really smart that seems somewhat
obvious but I suppose if you're in the
honeymoon period and you've just started
dating someone you're like yeah we never
argue it's great we're never stressed
out we're just happy together
everything's perfect it's like no no
matter who you're going out with
you just haven't seen them angry yet you
haven't seen them stressed yet right and
and maybe they're an angel over there
maybe you're not an angel but maybe
they're very manageable and you're like
oh wow this is you stressed that's
Rachel this is you able to communicate
when we had a problem like if you one of
the things I always say to people bring
this up early in a relationship even if
it's very mild bring up an issue
because it's symbolic of how somebody
deals like if you on you know date
number five say uh bring up and say hey
I just wanted to bring something up I'm
really enjoying you know seeing you but
this is the fifth time you've been a
little bit late and I just want to say I
I'm someone who doesn't do well with
that so I just wanted to bring up your
attention just to let you know that if
you could make efforts I'd really
appreciate it I understand that it can
happen but you say it nicely you say it
and if they go like and they might say
like oh you know I'm sorry I'll sorry I
know I'm like that I will definitely try
and make an effort that's nice if they
go like well what do you mean I'm late
so I was so late why are you making a
big deal out of it and you said it there
nicely and that's their response that's
also informative right but you can get
that information pretty early on by
being very nice in terms of how you
bring up a small thing just to see how
they discuss it
that's sneaky I like that I can remember
uh when I was I used to have health
problems which I do not anymore thank
goodness but when I was doing my like
Tinder dating which was just kind of
going out for coffee trying to meet
people
I can remember I was late one time and
somebody snapped at me and it was like
date two and I was late and they snapped
me and I was like oh and then I snapped
back at them it didn't go well anyway
good memories day two is inappropriate
for them to snap at you they should
actually be nice so that revealed
something you know that had you not been
late
you wouldn't have found out so so that's
what I'm saying but that's the thing bug
them a bit see what happens right so
when everything goes perfectly it's not
that everything's perfect it's that you
don't quite know yet
it might be it certainly might be yeah
you don't know yet
okay
let's see I have a whole bunch of
questions I want to ask you I just need
to pick which ones
okay this is a little bit different so
um I told you I've been kind of delving
into trauma and how to recover from
trauma
so how do you recover from shared
traumatic experiences so that you're not
setting each other off by reminding them
of the trauma you guys both have gone
through
what a great question and that's a bit
of a tricky one I think over this past
year and a half a lot of people have
been through yeah yeah experiences
quarantining together
well yeah but you know like I mean I I
live in New York City the you know it
was it was the epicenter at the
beginning a lot of people here that have
this look and they tell you oh the
sirens because that first month people
were just locked in their Apartments
afraid to go outside and all you had was
sirens day and night every several times
an hour you just couldn't get away from
it and so the sirens were so traumatic
it felt like the end of the world and
um yeah but how you get over trauma
number one is that two things I want to
say about that that a little
counterintuitive for people most people
think that the psychologist would say oh
if it's trauma you have to talk about it
you've got to bring it out you gotta
like you know get it out of your system
you have to debrief about it that's not
necessarily true there are people when
they've been through traumatic events
that feel the need to talk about them
and if you feel the need to talk about
the traumatic events you should but
there are people who go through the same
traumatic event and actually feel the
need to not talk about it they feel that
they'd rather
compartmentalize it and just kind of
move on I don't want to talk about it I
just want to move on and for those
people who don't want to talk about it
who are able to compartmentalize and
move on being forced to talk about it
um can actually be more scarring
um than not after 9 11 in New York City
there was one study that showed that the
more people spoke about the events the
harder it was for them to move past them
that the people who experience similar
events but didn't talk about them
because they didn't want to
um did better long term so it's an
individual thing you need to know
whether you feel the need to talk and
some people definitely feel the need to
I don't want to deal with it I just want
to move on
and and if you have to move on type then
it's not great for you to talk and if
you're the talker type it's important
and so that is also important when it's
two people because you hope to be
matched there I mean often it's one
person like I really want to talk and
the other person I really don't because
I don't want to get re-traumatized every
time you have a memory you're kind of
you're laying down that memory again and
so if you're bringing it up in a
traumatic way you're actually making
that trauma
worse and so for the person who doesn't
want to do it it's not wise for them to
then maybe the other person should find
you know someone to talk to who does
want to talk about things but even to
have that conversation what's your
preference do something you want to talk
about
Etc
this is the other thing about trauma
just the most you know known thing about
trauma is that the best way through it
is to um find meaning and you can only
do that in a certain distance of time
and and and emotional distance but
Define meaning to have a way to extract
something from that event that it taught
you that it showed you that you could
make changes based on and then it has
purpose or utility even if it was very
very difficult and that often takes that
edge
um off uh you know what the trauma does
uh the scars that it leaves
yeah purposeless suffering is much much
worse than suffering and learning
something or being able to help somebody
because you experience something or yeah
something like that does so you talked
about how some people are better or they
prefer to compartmentalize versus talk
about it does that have a lot to do with
how soon after the traumatic experience
occurred they're trying to delve into it
like if they wait a certain amount of
time then do some people go from
compartmentalizing it's hard to say to
talking about it
oh yeah I mean there can be an initial
shock period literally
um these uh you know the the in when
there's certain you know
um Mass events then then you have most
people who experience uh trauma or shock
are actually taken to hospitals for
evaluation the the non-physically
damaged are also taken to hospitals and
they're considered among the injured
because they are injured now that
initial shock
um subsides you know after however many
hours or days and then what are you left
with and so it may be in those in that
first few moments where you're still
coming to terms of what what happened
here
um it's hard to tell are you somebody
who needs to talk or or not but in the
days after again you will feel that need
uh once that shock is passed a bit to to
want to talk about it or you'll feel the
need to I don't and you'll know that
very clearly and it's very it's similar
with grief when people lose a relative
sometimes the assumption is because we
have all these rituals about the
community coming together to talk about
things but sometimes some people like
can we just not talk about them though
because I I I'm up for the distraction
but I just don't want to talk that's too
painful for me to talk about them so
even in grief sometimes people can can
have that choice but you know it because
you you feel like oh I don't want to do
this or I really want to do this I wish
somebody could listen you know that
right so
yeah it's complicated I've had a number
of experiences I wouldn't recommend I
mean everybody has
um and I've noticed
depending on the experience I'll either
go into I don't want to talk about it
like don't try and get into my head and
dissect whatever I'm thinking don't want
to talk about it to I need to write
about it or you know talking to a
therapist would help
um depending on how tough the situation
is maybe sometimes it takes a certain
period of time then I'm like okay now I
can talk about it but it's been a year
so I I you said something very important
there and that's the the the writing
part because writing is super super
useful because it helps you it's private
so you don't have to share it with
someone but it helps you organize your
thoughts because when we have
those big feelings attached to whatever
the traumatic event was was then it's
sometimes hard to you know like when
you're feeling that it's hard to
organize your thoughts because you're
feeling something so strongly it kind of
shuts down the minute we go back to our
to our more primitive uh uh in terms of
evolution uh our primitive structures it
takes away from our executive
functioning from the newer ones and so
I've you know the more upset we are the
the less thinking we can do with Clarity
writing forces emotional distance
because to translate what the thought
and feeling is into words that you then
organize and actually do the fine motor
skill of writing them down or typing
them it it is a laborious uh mental
execution that actually creates
emotional distance and then lowers the
emotional response enough for you to
have more clarity in your thinking about
it so it's very useful as a way to
especially when you're feeling a lot of
things to to or you're feeling things
very strongly to organize your thoughts
to get your own bearings before you then
you know like a lot of people say like I
can't talk just about anything to know
what I think first or what I feel first
well writing is a great way to get in
touch with it
okay I love that I found writing really
useful
um when I was actually I still do this
sometimes if I get really really wound
up in an argument or there's too many
things going on in my brain
and I'm in an argument with somebody
sometimes I find arguing over
by writing is actually
a good way to ease into that when I was
like going back to my first relationship
in high school before texting was really
a thing I would
and maybe this was weird but if I got
really mad about something I'd write it
down so I'd be able to tell them that
way but I didn't have the
I was too stressed out or worried like
just like I can't talk about this but
like this is why I'm angry
I found that really useful even though
it kind of felt like cheating
I don't think it's cheating at all and
look for for someone like me
um the the ideal there is what makes the
communication best
right I mean that's the goal like what
allows you to communicate best and for
you if you were to talk about it and you
would get upset and then it would be
harder to articulate what's going on
with you versus writing it down again
with that emotional distance it forces
and the ability to articulate things
because you can go and you can edit and
you can truly and some people actually
the you know are verbal expression in
our written expression is not uh aligned
with a lot of people some people are
much stronger in one than the other they
can speak amazingly right poorly or vice
versa so you writing was you
communicating as clearly as you could so
to me that's the win right I mean that's
the smart thing to do and I sometimes
recommend to couples who've been
together for a long time if they're
explosive if they tend to kind of go
from zero to War of the Roses in like
two sentences do it by a text do it via
emails because the other person won't
interrupt you they won't you know like
speak over you they won't start yelling
when you're in the middle of what you
want to say you actually get to finish
what you say they get to finish what
they say so if you're having trouble
communicating because it's too explosive
do it in text do it in writing that to
me that's that's not a cheat and it's
actually the more efficient
way to do it sometimes
okay that makes sense or if you're the
type of person like you said that was
explosive or you're going to get mad and
say something you don't mean if you're
writing it down then you can say okay
scratch that that isn't it you write it
and then you take it out exactly right
you're right
okay that's really helpful information
uh let's see
um I think I kind of asked this earlier
but
how do you know
okay I've seen couples that will stay
together for a very long period of time
and from the outside it just doesn't
look any good
and you can see that from the outside
but because they're in the relationship
they can't see that so are there signs
people should look for to know whether
or not they should just end the
relationship like you you talked about
people staying together or having kids
so they had something in common when
they don't
um are there signs you've seen in
couples where you're like
stop torturing yourselves
oh yeah
um the the research on on couples is
such that most couples therapists can
watch like a five minute snippet of a
couple argue
divorce with accuracies of over 90
percent oh
that's rough
um I as a therapist I tend to think is
great but okay yes
but it's not for the couple who's
arguing in that way why but why that is
is because it is how couples argue that
gives you a window into the relationship
satisfaction and longevity
it's how they process conflict and there
are several factors that have been shown
to you know both well to couples versus
both poorly for couples here's one
factor that bodes well I'll give you one
of each bodes well um there's something
called bids bids is you're sitting with
your partner and your partner you know
read something in the paper and goes oh
wow this is really interesting
that's a bid to connect because you're
then supposed to say oh what is it and
then they tell you and you go oh wow oh
this or that if they so if they say oh
wow this is really interesting and
you're like can't you see I'm working
not so good so the couples that offer
bids and respond to them have a great
prognosis
um it's a very positive sign that you're
offering bids to connect small minor
moments right and I gave this example of
a minor minor minor moment but if you
think of these moments as that was a bid
to connect
um and you respond to it that's very
good for couples
um what's very bad for couples is when
in an argument you quickly get to
contact
and you can see that and I've seen that
in my office and I've seen that
unfortunately at dinner parties where
you can see that one person annoys the
other and there's content there either
on the face or in the or in the language
like like almost discussed in how
they're talking like how could you even
like with this like facial expression
that's just makes you want to like as an
observer makes you want to oof that was
very very harsh but couples are doing
that to each other in public or they're
you know they get there very quickly
that's such a bad sign because if you so
quickly lose the connection lose the
love or respect you have for that person
and go so quickly to contempt which is
truly the opposite of love and respect
then that Foundation is not solid in any
way shape or form
um and so there's certain things like
you know there's contempt or there's you
know there's a lot of jokes that you
make at the other person's expense if
it's mild if it's truly funny if it's
not a big deal for the other person but
you sometimes hear it and you can see
the other person Flash hurt in their
eyes and this was at a dinner party and
you're like did you know you just
wounded emotionally you just hurt their
feelings in public and embarrass them
like well possibly would you do that it
happens all the time so those kinds of
things
are not good signs and putting out bids
and responding to them are good signs
okay what do couples who are at the
contempt stage Do Is there a way to
reverse that yes but in one condition
only if both of you are a mind to do
that because it will require both of you
to change a habit that depends on both
of you and that's how you're arguing
you need to learn to argue more
productively you need to learn to argue
with more empathy and compassion you
need to slow it down to understand the
other person before you get angry with
them like they said something that's
annoying why did they say it do they
really think that tell me more about
where that came from like you need to be
able to slow it down and get to
understand things
it is a big emotional effort in that
moment what your insights are telling
you is lash out lash out you know and so
you have to control that you have to
actually do the you know the thing of
like managing and regulating your
feelings and doing the difficult thing
and doing it because you hope that they
will afford you the same courtesy and
you can flip a dynamic from a very
negative one into a positive one but it
takes a lot of work this is where work
would be a lot of work and there are
couples and there are many who determine
that we really want this to work we got
into this bad habit let's really work on
changing it and when they really work
together that's what couples therapists
do all the time they can but if one of
them is in and the other one is like I
don't think I want to do it it's not
going to work and it certainly if both
are not of mine to do it or they just
don't have any rope left because they
just
I can't deal with this anymore then it's
not going to work
okay how do you identify a good couple's
therapist
are there places to go or yeah good
question yes um there are physical it's
do not assume that any therapist has
been trained as a couple therapist it's
fair when you go into a couple therapist
to say may I ask
um were you trained in couples therapy
and if they say oh you know I took a
class and I've just done it over the
years
you know if it's a referral from people
who know them and said yeah they were
great maybe but most people will be able
to say I did a master's program in
couples of family therapy I did four
years of training plus a postdoc in
couples and family therapy and then I
taught it for for many years in other
words you'll if you find people who've
actually got that credential who've
actually learned it in clear programs
who teach it who are known for it
they're going to be much more skilled at
doing it it's very different modality
than individual therapy you have to be
much more active as a couples therapist
If You Take Your Eye Off the Ball again
think of an explosive couples if you get
lost in your own thought for a minute
suddenly world war three is going on in
your office and you're like oops how did
that happen so you've got to be really
on it you have to be able to really
multitask and think of what's going on
here here and in your head about what
needs to happen it's so you know you
want somebody who's either been referred
because they've done a very good job
with somebody you know or you're very
fair to ask and by the way if you're
asking any position or any therapist
about their specific skill set oh you do
this where did you learn it and they get
defensive
no yeah not a good sign it's a very very
fair question there's zero reason to get
defensive I get asked that still and you
know I'm at a certain level of people
just I'm awaiting this to people waiting
to see me I still get out did you learn
this I think very fair question I will
tell them if I did and if I didn't I'll
say no so maybe I'm not the best person
for you
yeah you don't need a volatile therapist
trying to help your volatility right you
want somebody well trained if you're
volatile right you want somebody who you
know can manage the situation and and
help you rather than just feel
overwhelmed by what's going on
that makes sense okay how do you tell
when someone you've been talking with
for a while whether or not they're
interested in you that seems like a
simple question but I'm gonna ask it
anyway
two things number one don't look at
anything they say only what they do
so literally ignore words you know they
say oh no I'm really interested and
you're so great and
what are the actions
who's initiating the get-togethers how
quickly are they contacting you after
you get together
um how quickly do they respond to your
texts how much are they writing
literally counting sentences counting
lines how many lines did they write to
how many lines that you're writing
um and so you can see this is somebody
who seems like they're pursuing me or
that they're interested and they might
not be pursuing but they're very
responsive you know it's text messages
if it takes you more than 24 hours to
respond
you'd have better been in you know in
surgery either as a the surgeon or the
person getting surgery
um like there's there's it's there's no
if you're interested there's very little
circumstance maybe you're traveling but
there's very little circumstancing but
you can't just say sorry busy but I'll
text tomorrow like something that's
responsive
um or let someone know you know I'm
going into this very busy week I won't
be able to like but you know a lot of
times people are like well I texted and
I didn't hear back I'm still waiting the
date went so well but it's been two days
and I'm like they're not trying to let
you know that they're interested maybe
they still are but and maybe and then
when they come back on day three do they
go I'm so sorry I got so swamped with
work or do they say pretend like no
that's normal that we spent five hours
together on Sunday and it's Wednesday
before I say something
that shows a little bit less interest to
me right and so and again if they
address it and say oh I'm sorry I was
you know then they're at least aware
that no there was an intention there to
communicate
soon or more quickly so you know I think
oftentimes people have that gut feeling
they kind of know they just want to hope
that maybe it's more positive than it
feels but when somebody is interested
you usually feel it because they make
you feel they're interested and if you
don't feel it then it's maybe to know
no no it's maybe that if that you know
when it is
that totally makes sense okay what
happens if you're texting somebody
and
they're not responding very well so it's
not going very well and you're like
forget it but then every time you don't
respond for a while they'll ping you
again
um
it's such a common pattern right and
it's so frustrating to people when that
happens and I think that the response to
that should be
um when they ping you again how long do
they wait to pick you
you wait that long to respond and when
you do respond say oh hey you know I was
busy but to be honest with you I'm happy
to get together again if you want but
unless you know I don't really have a
ton of time for just texting for another
month before we do that so kind of you
know people get off the park or you know
like you can just be very clear about it
like look at a fun time but
um if you want to get together and
explore another date that's fine if not
no problem but you know it's I I don't
don't have time to do the back and forth
too much I mean you can say it nicely in
some way yeah but you know
yeah it's reasonable to expect that you
know because that's a classic pattern of
somebody that's putting you on hold or
keeping you or not really serious so
yeah you don't have to comply with it
you can just say like hey you know what
um you seem busy or otherwise
preoccupied so it was nice to know you
but you know if you want to check in
with me when you have the bandwidth
that's great and otherwise we'll you
know see each other around whatever you
say do it nicely obviously if you want
to leave the door open a little bit but
you want to be clear that um
okay that makes sense is that
um just between in like a relationship
between a man and a woman
is that more normal for a man to be less
responsive or is that a sign that you
should maybe not be as interested As You
Are
men will tell me is this normal for a
woman to be this unresponsive she must
be getting so many you know swipes okay
I'm just one of them and and women
always say well you know he's always so
I really think it kind of goes both ways
depending on the person but here's what
I say I'm like
when you're texting with someone right
it might go from you know a day to
texting or texting to a date but that it
might be the early steps of a
relationship that ends up forming or not
if it if they are early steps then you
have to understand that you're kind of
negotiating something in an unspoken way
you're negotiating a dynamic and it's a
dynamic that you are agreeing to is I
reach out to you in a timely manner you
don't respond in a timely manner
then I respond in a timely manner then
you don't respond in a time you are
setting up a dynamic in which I will
make more effort in this than you do you
don't have to make as much effort as I
do is the unspoken Dynamic that you're
kind of agreeing to which you do not
want to agree to so that's why you have
to pay attention to these early steps
and I think texting is so useful because
you can literally whenever a patient
said to me I said I want to show me your
phone because I want to see in that look
they wrote two lines you wrote six then
they wrote one word then you wrote two
lines you are constantly putting in more
effort than them just visually
and it comes across so you are setting
up this Dynamic where you will try
harder and you don't want to set up
Academic Way you want something that's
more fluid where the whole chunks where
they write a lot and then you write a
little then it flips over that's back
and forth but you will often see that
it's very skewed it's like one person
making more effort than the other don't
do that at the beginning you're setting
something up that will be hard to change
later on you're letting them know that
to be with you doesn't take that much
effort and the answer should always be
to be with me takes a little bit of
effort I put in that effort I expect to
get it back and you can control that
with the texting then you wait also even
if you're dying to respond to them you
wait you go sorry I was busy at work
because it's no biggie for them to be
busy at work it's not biggie for you you
shouldn't make it more urgent for you
than it is for them but pay attention
early on
ah so you have to so you have to be
paying attention you have to kind of
play into that game to set up boundaries
near the beginning
look true but here's the reality and
it's a harsh reality it's like cement
relationship Dynamics are like cement
they dry very quickly
and then they Harden and it's hard to
change them you can change them before
they're dry at the beginning but they
dry quickly so pay attention to those
smooth things you are actually setting
up a tacit you know unspoken agreement
to something that you know you think oh
I'll change that later this event will
be drier it'll be way harder to do that
later change it yeah
okay that makes sense thank you very
much for coming on uh if anybody wants
to follow you or learn more or listen to
your podcast where should they go what
should they type in
so they can put in guywinch.com that's
g-u-y-w-i-n-c-h.com that's my website
they'll find links to my TED Talks the
podcast podcast is called dear
therapists they can get it wherever they
get their podcasts and on Instagram and
Twitter I'm at guy winch and I'm guy
winch author on Facebook
perfect thank you very much for coming
on thank you so much for having me
[Music]